[Music]
welcome and we are laughs welcome to the
i lords podcast episode number 76 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable and the Lord's
Day I'm extremely excited about a
special guest you'll get right into it I
want to introduce the Lord who in my
opinion has one of the most recognizable
and iconic radio voices in the entire
realm of gaming podcasts not only is
this Lord of hosts one of the best Xbox
centric platforms in the game his
knowledge and passion for gaming truly
resonates while still providing great
entertainment with extremely high
production values introducing the host
of the crossfire podcasts and mooch and
crap in the mornings the godfather to
many of your favorite youtubers and
despite any misunderstandings in the
past the Lord currently focused on the
common thread that drives us all our
passion for video games hmm fellow
destiny Fame yes fellow New York City
sports fan yes making his debut into the
realm of the Lord's my main Lord mooch
how you doing sir man that is an intro
that is it blows me away man listen to
be here with you guys right now I've
been looking forward to this and we've
been talking about this offline for a
minute and it makes this happen is and I
think your gift that you sent out
yesterday right really like we are gonna
make these two realms come together
that's what we're here to do we're here
to talk about our passion what drives us
the games we love what brought us to
this in the first place and we're gonna
bring both audiences together for the
first time today on the Lord's Day so it
is an honor and a privilege to be here
with every one of you guys thank you
Lord that much appreciate very well said
super high yes sir overdue treaty signed
efficient we're gonna do this thing
gonna have some fun we gonna talk games
mix that's what yeah yeah you already
know and of course we had the Four
Horsemen of game
and those usual suspects at the round
table my co-host with the co-host my
brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror and the house
of the young my maid Lord addict how are
you doing sir doing pretty good pretty
much destiny actually I've been playing
Wolfenstein I played South Park I beat
it this week that's the difficult game
every day on the road
South Park is not an easy game when you
know that easy
at the very end man I was like man like
I beat it on my first try but I was like
I can't believe that just went down no
doubt difficult game conquer in a
building another one notched up and of
course we have our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience in also
the sastra Thomas mr off my profile
Illuminati and Lord patreon of the iron
bank my man
Lord sovereign are you doing sir do a
good man doing fantastic but actually I
just behind the background what goes on
and making those thumb nose but it's
like to us trees being made for everyone
I put the text in the chat yo was
everybody's really talking to me even
though chastising you to the throat
headed in this segment sobbing I'm so
I've been playing I've been playing
destiny Blues were you online I was
online kinky bottom me let me explain
when I get to my fraud report y'all
going here at all we got a lot of guys
out here Lord and fraud let me elaborate
on my please all right so I got my blues
right I love y'all stupid stupid i'ma
tell you right now you to allow
yourselves to be bamboozled by this game
oh I can't I can't go there with you
guys until you do it man I did my greens
and thank you the King Thank You them Oh
hot monkey shout somebody help me mm-hmm
so when I get there I get my blues and I
look at what I have to do I'm like you
see this this is why the green one but
it's not the point the point is making
you do the same stuff over and over
again talking about do I need to be gone
like four five
he talked about the Redux missions yeah
that's why Ducks is a little more I got
it gifs on it it is so question once I
finished the blues right yes do I have
to do the same Oh brilliant
you don't have no purple different yeah
purple is real like you and purple
requires you to play with friends so now
questions questions now is there is
there a thing for forsaking where like
if you haven't caught up you know you
just yes they usually do it yeah
protecting what they gave the token or
something like that I'm with you sob I'm
with you because here's the thing I said
the same thing I'm stuck on the blues
right now right and that's not because
I'm stuck I can't do it I'm stuck
because of time and I'm running out of
time but what is it 28th is done right
28th right number listening Cognito and
just they set me straight in the
pre-show okay they told me that once we
get I said once you get the purple we
have the rest of the time before
Forsaken to finish that up to get to for
mass yeah so we're good you're good I
know I know we're doing tonight no and
then you guys make me feel bad for not
being in them like are you kidding me
I'm not used to being able to talk about
destiny this openly we had a meet like
it's some kind of quarter talk about it
where they leave you a note here's where
I hang out is today that's what it is
I'm swear to god there's no less a cross
fire does not just not a destiny yes
okay bodies well he's you see him you
guys I know a couple you guys are in our
destiny thread he keeps adding it's like
half Hannity communities in that thread
right now but like work for a pistol
yeah it is
I can't keep I just can't go meet with
him but to be honest with you and this
is
destiny - you know for a lot of people
they don't get it and I'm not talking
anybody into the game right but and I
think you lords will understand what I'm
saying here but realistically what that
game is is the community game it's the
key what it is because we all step away
and then we all come back yes and that's
the thing for you to do that you could
step away and stuff we could call frauds
and weekly shows what we said destinies
probably dead and we got you back of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gave up the Lord of
combat sports who was a man of his
convictions the man's nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement we're
doing fantastic we got a lot of dudes
out here Lord and fraud report so let's
check this out you know uh I want to
give a hard shout out to all the lords
Lord in the fraud and jumping in my
auntie's like you King I was going on
with all this destiny the Solstice our
weather were days are over
what you doing and I'm like okay and you
know you see them get on and I can't lie
a lot of these guys only play at a
certain time and a lot of these guys
like I can't really get on Lord addict
too much because he's streaming
throughout the week he's our he's the
leader and part of the the stream team
you know and so he has to do a lot of
content on different games so if he does
jump in a party on the Saturday and he
is rocking a green or blue I look at him
with the Snyder but I said monkey go
handle him you know take him through
monkey nose arm the rigor amo of the
stuff to get it done yeah used
I said I was rigmarole you got it then
you got you know Lord sovereign he
jumped Lord Lord fraud but I the reason
why I can call him Lord fraud because I
understand how he games but also
remember this he truly gains
multi-platform
so he will be on a Playstation
completing games one spider-man and we
don't care we understand your fraud it's
cool I catch you fraud and all the time
you jump in boy but you put in your
house i'ma knock this out King your king
okay we get this dead King and I'm like
all characters master works everything
is done we have a lot of people in the
clan listen this this is some true facts
all right we have a lot of people in the
clan that are getting messages and are
getting invites and they're not joining
they're not trying to figure out what's
going on with other clan members to see
what it needs to be done
alright and and this Fork report isn't
just for destiny yeah guys I got some
other stuff for you in a second but if
somebody sends me an invite I would just
want you to look and see if he's in
there on your clan and if he is in your
clan even if you you can't do something
just check in there see what's up y'all
watch on me what's the what's going on
because I want you for a quick second
only guys yeah Lord Lord dizzy I want to
shout him out and the those guys that
came over man really much appreciated
the whole crew Reaper Frodo has already
been down zero has already been dead you
know I'm saying but to see them get
together he told me like you know cause
like Rose you know my wife he you know
people were coming and message to her
hey you need help with this stuff like
that so he's like I want to know so we I
want to shout out the ones that are
doing it cuz I telling I'm telling
actively we go through the list we check
in your clothes
he lets me looking at the rain reports
throughout the list we I like see know
what's he got a chance to run with the
a-team he actually sees how to 18 moves
so when we gone we take any sharper and
people do
these are people has never done raised
shout out to destiny for putting that in
the game that you're able to pick people
up they have absolutely no skill and
then range and you can take them and
show them how to do range and that's how
we're adding people to the clan because
a lot of these people are highly skilled
to do these raids but they don't have a
clan I told you before if you're
actively playing and you have to look
around for friends come to us don't
worry about it we'll take you I don't
want these people that just want the
whisper start out the booty time captain
fraud gotta gotta gotta gotta call you
off a fraud on that captain all the time
yeah I think I think your buddy
bootytime was gonna get kicked out the
clan now y'all listen Buddha I love you
I love you Buddha but your fraud no you
Sony dude I'm listen I know a fraud when
it comes to Xbox stuff when y'all told
me to crack and didn't have a body I had
your owner to my fraud right that's
spider-man though yo J dubs to the line
listen y'all was on my Twitter line at
least yesterday for ten hours talking
about the same thing broaden about how
Microsoft got the services and all this
other stuff and then you're going in on
spider-man listen that pictures are not
the same Sony's out have frodan but if
you'd not to own up feel fraud if you
die back in the bookies own and I got
the pictures and the facts I saw you
your fraud and calling you out
recruitment I hope people forward report
and of course we have needles right now
realness in the realm of the ILP now
tell you what you want to hear what you
need to hear me it's been pretty much
the same everybody at rest of lords
destiny - you know majority no and I'm
actually fandom doctrine just released
it's a XCOM style game you guys are big
fans excellent please XCOM please check
it out have it up on the iron royal
podcast YouTube channel little
walkthrough it's kind of like a mix of
ex humble with spy and espionage
mechanics really cool really fun shout
out to those guys over there at cold
fusion games and creative watch games
and a Good Shepherd Entertainment
definitely liked what they was doing
over there and of course Laura saw Rio
the legend Shenmue return why I don't
like tank controls I remember on the
Dreamcast don't know much if you had
shin hwal your boy mooch is in the works
right now mooch in Shenmue wanna try my
damnedest you got it when you gotta go
back and let me tell you something where
I'm just saying that to go sob nostalgia
is a hell of a draws you all right you
do realize we all take that drug every
single time these old games come right
listen we've all been there right since
the beginning at NES days maybe before
maybe you guys don't want to admit it
but you would ever Coleco was around is
this okay we played those games we had
those memories we had that that feeling
we have with those aimed at connection
but you gotta admit and this is a me
problem probably look realistically
here's my issue the minute I popped
these games back on I realized that that
memory was better with
better left in the bush let it be you're
not lying
there's a lot of accuracy to what you
say hey I told you so but I'm still
having fun my only things I just don't
like to try just wish they had an
updated control scheme because he goes
around like a tank and just to look at
an item or a cabinet in a room it's
really frustrating shouldn't I shouldn't
have to draw the controllers game
usually that's the one thing they always
do yeah
again maybe I haven't found I got a mess
around with the base little but I will
say cuz again coming from the Dreamcast
Lord King remembers no going between a
door and an outside area with the
loading would be atrocious so the
loading is fantastic so it really makes
things if me and smooth and my thing is
right off the bat bass off had to put
the jump Japanese dub on bro with the
tech so it felt like a true kung fu
flick 1970 that's what I needed about it
the thing about it is like at the
beginning of the road it's only it's
only like his father gets murdered and
like two days later they all right now
already playing this week want to start
off with Lord mulch his video game
system history and of course would let
him to become one of the early pioneers
and I call him the Godfather one of the
godfathers of the Xbox YouTube movement
so long mooch let's start from the very
beginning with some og gaming talk what
was some of the first video game systems
you had and what got sheena gaming so
realistic so you show your age here but
I'll pretend that I bought him after the
fact but right it was the whole like
Coleco that Coleco thing you that's
that's dating ourselves alright my
system getting into that zaxon playing
we thought what we thought was the
arcade in our living room back in the
day you realize that the arcade was on
the way with that
yes right so lot of people don't really
realize this about me they think just
because I'm Xbox guy that I don't listen
I grew up on JRPGs I grew up with the
way that the NES up listen I know I
think I'm in good company here but a lot
of people that are Xbox fans are all
Sega right I was NES all day and I went
to war oh I want to get back to your
question to me no I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna venture off that beat but you know
console wars is healthy if it's done
properly okay it's been going on since
before any of us even picked up a guitar
tours low-key how push competition
that's correct
thank you that's what I'm saying that
that's that's the whole thing I've been
trying to to push through and say listen
if we do it in the right manner right
and we all kind of and we've all kind of
gone through these motions over the past
four or five years it is good for the
business and you know that fill-in
yoshida are sitting there with big grins
when we go back and forth they're like
look at these fools buying bulk
everything so we're doing there but
getting back to the subject no listen I
was a Nintendo guy I was hardcore on
that I loved loved loved like The Legend
of Zelda I love love love Final Fantasy
listen there was a reason I was tweeting
earlier this morning about getting on
that okto path traveller okay that's
pretty old memory right so realistically
speaking I've been gaming since man
before I'm even wanting to talk about be
game for a long time but realistically
you know with time things change and I
got into the world of like you saw the
halo and the first-person shooter and I
think that's why I have a hard time
sometimes going back on back and living
in those Shenmue days or going far
enough back to say like I can't wait to
get back in the Final Fantasy 7 I want
to see it I might want to experience it
but I don't know if I want to get lost
in it again let me ask you a question so
yeah Lomo show you more of a fan of a
remake than a remaster so you guys in
the class
game-2 like you rather than build it up
with today's assets yes in more of a
modern field and actually just porting
up and we know a resolution of the same
kind of again kind of like what should
we kind of done right now yeah exactly
that's what shen motors got like what
Shenmue has brought the 4k maybe some
for care they're trying their best to
get to that that image texture right
there's technically is a trying to get
to cleaning the lines up a little bit
they're making the UI a little bit more
crisp so it's not that faded to X look
that's fine but realistically it's
really just a paint job so you don't I'm
saying so realistically what I like to
see is I like to see what they did now
and correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe like crash bandicoot right that
was built that was rebuilt from the
ground up I believe I believe yeah but
it was still the same fading it's not
like this Resident Evil 2 when I
Resident Evil 2 that dad statin is
really a good-looking different take on
it you know so that's whether using a
whole new engine yeah they're using the
bio biohazard engine on that the
Resident Evil 7 engine all they see like
that is just a quick buck they put it
has a low output and you you know go out
there as to how much was shimmy even
even if you know the games don't play
any different from 15 years ago right I
think $30 is fair for two games no three
looking pretty spooky to someone gonna
side by side and a little key saw it
move like the part one lindy face
rendering better than the three I got
you I don't want to pull you back just a
bit cuz I know you said click on all
that good stuff I know it wasn't
give me those Nintendo system what's the
kind of your order chronologically of
what you had from a console standpoint
well that's it right up that
Chane so you're talking about so we went
from Coleco to nes SNES genesis okay
gamecube then we went and I even got the
game gear I even got the small portable
it's sitting listen I'll snap a picture
if I have to I sitting right in front of
me I actually have it on the wall I have
yes like I got into every single you
know PlayStation 1 PlayStation 2
PlayStation 3 had those all the way up
to the current day I've been playing on
everything but just like everything in
life right I know everybody on this
panel probably had a Ford you'd had a
Chevy you had at this but when someone
says you what's your favorite you got
one yes realistically per generation and
it's been this way for a while you know
it even took me a while a lot of people
I've said this on different shows I've
said it on my own show is that I hyung
will quit I was with PlayStation 2 even
when the OG xbox came like I was still
playing Lully yeah it'd be a minute to
come over I didn't see that and just
fall in love with a lot of people of God
you saw it and I fell in love with it it
takes mucho a while to come around well
I though I finally got into the Xbox
vibe when I saw what they were doing
first-person shooters to change that but
getting back to the past cuz there's a
couple people in the chapter like couch
tell us a little bit about oh I really
did get into the JRPGs and we made it a
family thing right that was our thing
when we were kidding we're kids right we
were my dad's was into gaming so he
wanna see so yes right so is the same
thing we try to do now with the family
who try to genuinely get together we do
we thought that's why I think it's
important to have all the if you can if
I would say this if it's within your
financial means you should have all the
consoles because why deprive the kids
let them try and let them fly on their
own pass right reach so we didn't have
these we didn't have I just told you I'm
dying I'm dying are deep down inside my
you guys right I just did okay
the kids and it's funny though right
when we were all growing up we didn't
have that opportunity cuz I even though
I had all those wasn't like I was
privileged to get them all day one I'm
talking
these are spread over years before I got
them I didn't get Genesis for a while
after the SNES I mean I'm talking about
years not months not weeks like look at
all of us now we're like maybe I will go
get the PS 5 after I get the Xbox 2 but
that's a privilege we have nowadays how
things are set up we're gonna get it
we're gonna get into Xbox of all access
and we're gonna talk about this today
and that's a that's a huge selling point
we should talk about absolutely like we
had to appreciate look at look at the
game ghosts and goblins mmm Oh Bri heart
allowed the curse in the house but I
wanted to write that pain right there
right I would I played that til my
fingers bled okay super ghosts and
goblins oh yeah did you have the super
graphic spoon because I had a turbo
graphics I had a turbo duel and super
graphics graphics we used to get the
imports like one year ahead of us
release so we things out we had to mess
around with the UI figure what the hell
we were doing and I my playstation the X
and the circle button will reversed for
the jam don't tell me that's not
bothering you guys too with the switch
it mentally messes approve that on the
menu screen alone if not listen but
realistically like getting back to it
like before they don't realize
listen everybody on this panel thank God
I feel like I'm at home people love
destiny right so destiny you know you
get so far and maybe you're trying to do
something on your own you're doing the
nightfall or something you die you're
like please God don't let it go all the
way back yeah
that's right even if you're not holy you
are praying this up in the minute you
die not fade the light goes up so I'm
like alright listen
thank God they only brought me halfway
back whatever my point is we were kids
everybody on this panel knows this when
we were kids
mm-hmm they don't know these people that
they don't know what difficulty is you
had three lives yes three that came in
one sitting
it was your friends would ring the
doorbell we're playing basketballs like
not today
yeah I got one life left in two hours
ago that's the way life was you had to
like you pause the game you ate you came
back and you were focused that's what
you was like oh my god you can die at
least after that Marsha remember that
mushroom used to pop up for the one up I
jumped on that like a football on the
one-yard line
oh when you used to have to like turn
the TV off and change the channel to let
the parents come home working on a
Saturday she said you were playing video
games where you know I was like I just
quickly switch that a B switch yeah you
don't even know to a B switches and if
you don't don't worry about it go ahead
was a great thing oh here it goes Doris
what you wouldn't agree it was the
little box these guys don't know is
utensils and tools to get in the back of
your TV
you get electrocuted yourself you really
did scissors needed a butter knife you
got back to you screwed it in and always
those wires broke
have to take this the the the copper
wire and wrap it around screw make sure
it stays good HDMI in this is another
reason everybody on this panel doesn't
mind is you remember the whole talk
about Xbox getting rid of the power
brick and people are upset about it
I used to say why are we so worried
about that power brick it's a one time
and done do you remember that Coleco and
sega power block that we plugged into
the wall what it has the little screw on
the bottom so it could actually stay
there it was so heavy would fall out
that was hard times
somebody gets a survivor to play some
Nintendo what shout out the 40 piece we
had terrible those TVs were so heavy
that we had a floor model but we had a
team you on top of the floor you had a
television it was furniture you actually
said something one of our first guests
you know first person what you really
say you mentioned the game gear right
and I want to talk about we don't get a
chance that really mentioned portables
right like how big were portables back
then because I know for me gangee was
big another battery life a little no
rough you know I said but you know gate
I was the age game boy and I got a bear
miss me I was an Atari Lynx Atari any
handheld that's on your Microsoft is
made I don't know where all the lords
are living right now I know a couple of
you cats are definitely on the East
Coast okay we're all East Coast you guys
will get this right mm-hmm
listen I got the switch and even with
the portability things like we're
talking about Game Gear are you talking
about Game Boy realistic
if you work on on a family trip which is
rare that that portability went from
sitting on the floor in front of that
furniture console we used to have to sit
on the couch yes now I can sit on the
couch and play the game because now in
front of the television set that is true
that was traveling I travelled to the
couch we take that for granted - now
that these controllers reach out the
couch that wasn't the way it was back oh
oh cataracts is real you see all these
like these gaming media sites that are
on the west coast they're like I took my
switch up through the roof
I took my switch over I'm like we don't
do that over here on the East Coast I
never took my switch to go get a
sandwich boat you mean that the switch
combro sure wasn't realistic - you know
top party parties in New York because
our rooftops are 75,000 stories high
right they got a sign up water some kind
of things they don't sue you when you're
on top of a roof in New York we don't do
that here we do ropes around these kind
of areas there aren't even built to be
on single roof in New York like they
built their roofs to do [ __ ] like that
snow and stuff they don't the wind maybe
you make a good point there at because I
think what it is is that here in New
York and I'm not speak for every
household it depends on your water table
level but like we have basements people
talk about man caves I think out there
they don't have basements maybe that is
useful square footage is incredible
those Vegas shows on HGTV and they show
you California like now we're gonna go
up to the roof and I'm like the roof
okay
and people on the basketball court with
this which is oh my god unrealistic this
is hilarious I will say I am the guy in
this version that does it on the plane
I'm not going - switch when I went to LA
and when I went to pax mm-hmm I can't
like I'm uneasy when I'm on a plane so I
can't like focus on a switch I have to
go to sleep like I have to well here's
what I want to ask kognito though if you
were using it on the plane explain this
- because I've done it to tell the
audience about the looks you get all the
people sitting across the hall like I'm
very listen I want to turn around to
them and say is that a grown man you get
a crossword puzzle
exactly Zion is clearly you're
interesting because I never saw a child
go inside a store pull out his credit
cards are fortunate to have parents that
really care to buy them these systems
really make I got a good mood you know
is with this wage like a child like do
you did that feel alone you don't like
when you pop those joy cause that's when
you're free come out you feel like you
the club the glow stick like that oh
good on a par with those root parties
people were like let me give you a
context no one's saying that I want to
close
I don't want that little junior MIT in
my hand right you see like little tic
tacs for the a/b button it's okay they
give you protection for you yes they do
yes they do
we got that going
so now as like I said both of us nope
let's talk about just Xbox per se
because you did say PlayStation you know
that you everybody everyone had that ps2
it was just dominate it was drained Xbox
kind of comes out as the new kid on the
block you know we're a little skeptical
you know a lot of us but so long it's
like what kind of got you into the echo
ecosystem like what made you say okay
this is what I'm talking about and
really kind of galvanized you as far as
one of your favorite brands
it was favored wasn't it going through
your console history and you had the
PlayStation 2 and in the original og
comes out you know you were kinda on the
fence cause you said mooch doesn't just
run out and get every doll dressed no so
like what kind of thing what got you
over the hump into the Xbox oh so listen
so we're talking about going all the way
from oh one and realistically I've got a
fast forward to about oh seven away in
it oh yes it was my brother he brought
he had he was really into it so he went
and grabbed 360 when a 360 first came
out you know I'm still holding on to
that PlayStation know he brings me over
right he brings me over an Xbox he's
like it's time to get real
brings me over the Xbox and slaps down
Gears of War oh and let me tell you
something
that's when the [ __ ] hit the fan I'm
like this is real right here this is
when I said what's going on
why am I still on this [ __ ] you want my
thought what the hell is going on over
here on this Xbox and that was it and
maybe you might call it late to the
party here it is in 2018 CNN a 2007 was
a minute ago but realistically it's kind
of late to the party right but that was
the game that opened my eyes right that
was when I saw the world in color right
I was like this is what's happening
this is crazy let me tell you let me
take someone's because you're hitting it
on the head like that game
I remember the trailer King commercial
you know that cold world song yes and
him Marcus Fenix shooting it was just me
means all these aliens coming at him it
was it blew my mind that that was a tone
piece and I believe shout out to all my
McCaffrey shout out to Peter Moore I
believe I'm careful shows excellent yeah
like it was kinda like the generations
of Xbox war he had respect Phil and when
Peter was talking I he talked about the
boardroom when they brought that in a
show them and how a mostly like people
like they've never seen everything it
was a silence like it like that cold
world trailer made me want to pick up
kids I'll never forget I'm glad you said
that that game was man for its time you
know that interview you're talking about
that interview you're talking about if
no one has seen it that is a great
interview to watch to see Peter Moore
Phil and our boy Shane is sitting there
and and you can see by the way each of
them talks about their experience
through xbox right how hard I mean you
want to talk about being a pioneer okay
and I know we're gonna get into I think
one of the questions you have for me too
you know what you know how I got into
Xbox yeah excuse me not just Xbox with
YouTube and the whole thing that we all
do today right and and here's the thing
before we get into that to see Seamus
blackly and what he had to do to preach
to the CEOs at the time that this was
going to be something that man is open
to discuss all types of games with every
one of us right that man climbed the the
tallest steepest mountain to get to get
where Xbox is today where you know
people like well Phil Phil how to preach
this and fill out a preach that no doubt
he did where shame is blackly when he
walked in and was like so this Xbox
right they were like yeah all right
right yeah somebody can somebody tell
him that we need more water in the water
cooler yeah you know me like this man
went to war for everybody that's why I
was Seamus I don't care what he tweets
whatever he tweets I'm like retweet that
oh yeah
fantastic point on which because like
you said out shame is like them in the
console space was considered a joke if
you listen to many stories been on
numerous podcast and people forget to
struggle like Windows was so dominant
back then and it was just anything like
Microsoft into gaming it was like an
afterthought so for hitting the pioneer
that you're right he doesn't get enough
credit as the father xbox like him JL
and all those guys like that was like
wow you know they just to try to push
that forward because it was it was so
much pushback and they get that thing
out and people say that og wasn't
successful and I get that but that kind
of laid the foundation Peter and then
fail and all those guys to kind of get
the thing going man yes the ball was
rolling in the cell they each of them
had their struggles everyone had their
trials and tribulations through being
the CEO of you know the head of Xbox but
realistically when you see what the guys
had to do back in the day - like we just
discussed it right now when we take this
switch on the road or we have these
shows we have people that work all of us
a lot of my friends in life they say hey
there's like really you go home and play
video games I go you really go home and
watch the voice don't tell me you're
gonna sit there and watch the boys for
two hours three days a week like we're
putting hand-eye coordination to work
okay besides movies video games was
pushing television technology yeah yes
you know what you don't understand is we
were gaming on for 80 90 140 P it was
sub 480p 480i remember interlace
remember that we it didn't get pushed
forward until the medium of movies and
video games they saw the market it's not
a pushing it forward DVDs brought the
clarity up now HD DVD vs. blu-ray
brought the clarity up so it pushed it
into everybody's homes and we're pushing
the technology along with the PC to push
these graphics and these television
resolutions all the way up they talk
about 8k now and all right I'm pretty
sure these new systems coming out later
is gonna try some okay one of them
you couldn't have preached any better
than what you just said there was no way
okay you go back before videogames hit
like mainstream media like it is now we
were holding on the TV's for a decade
maybe a decade plus and now you got
people who just bought a 4k being like
maybe I could get something if they got
the free sickening maybe I'll switch up
after three years that's what this
gaming industry has done it does promote
the technology is moving at a rapid rate
but we might not have made that move
financially if it wasn't for maybe use
video games okay good point can you pull
out you guys they'll agree cuz I
remember what the OG xbox like hey you
need either net like it's no mirror
dial-up you know like an Xbox doesn't
get enough credit for pushing a lot of
things for like there was certain things
hard to tell with the Xbox when it came
out with Xbox Live would internet be
where it is because the gaming industry
pushed the the internet industry to
where they had increased because people
want to play these games so they had to
compete with each other to get the best
form out mhm yeah yeah even with the
television market right when it 360 came
out like 720p 8 that was like to stay in
the system had HDMI built it was a a big
thing for this evolution that she
changed the crossover yes absolutely man
so back to mooch man like whoa history
bad so that that was with did it so yeah
I got that's what I did it - no that was
me my transference God's about
transition because obviously you got a
big history and then you know the whole
getting into youtube right and you we've
talked offline like I got one of these
iconic voices you don't say like radio
thank you to duty so how did that whole
passion now translate into getting into
YouTube how did that start yeah and you
know this is a great this is a great
story man I enjoy telling it because a
lot of people don't know and that's
what's great about coming on the show
and you know to talk to your audience as
well is you know so we had this passion
every one on this panel has this passion
built and that's why we're doing it but
I'm sitting there okay back in 2012
2013 and I'm sitting there and I'm doing
all this reading and you know I'm
excited because we've all waited too
damn long between last generation and
the generation we're currently in and I
was amped and I saw the great potential
that was coming out of I said we'd like
to see technology kind of roll forward
so I saw these things that the Xbox one
was doing and I know the media didn't
care for it but I did I like the idea of
Kinect did I like Kinect games not
really but I liked what the Kinect I had
we are moving forward going in to two
points the Kinect being one of them the
other one is the HDMI IN okay because
now when I come home just like everybody
does in their household okay
puts on their television now I could put
my television on and I can know that my
friend King is playing I can know that
cos Leto is on I can know Saab is on I
know addict is hitting me up to play
destiny and if I can't I can message you
back and say I'll get with you later
okay this is what I saw coming down the
pipeline and when I saw that the ps4 was
just gonna be a better look in ps3 I
said okay alright
that's fine that's what we do in
progression right we are going forward
but when I saw Microsoft was taking the
360 up and then giving me things I
didn't even know we could do okay that's
when I said so to get back into it so I
saw all this happening and I saw all
this negativity coming from the media
right so we saw all this we all saw it
with our own eyes right here I am i
flipping through youtube I'm checking
stuff out YouTube to me still kind of
new you know YouTube back in the day you
go back to 2011 and before YouTube was
like how do you fix your washer and
dryer so bugs so I'm sitting there and
all of a sudden just like you know he
says it I'm gonna give him credit to say
I stumbled upon zaire watch it shout out
to say that he the true godfather got
yeah that's right
I don't go on one show without giving
credit where credit's due
inside here is he is the original the
pain I felt Godfather alerts have to
give credit have to whether you like the
content or not he is absolutely the man
who started also but I'm watching I said
this man has got it first of all I year
should be doing more than YouTube that
man is pure he knows how to entertain
he knows how to people
laughs and that's something that you can
write things you can do script
something's just come natural I was
drawn right to Z's channel so I go there
and I said I'm sitting there so I watch
and I'm watching just his ten minute
segments I'm watching only then I start
watching him doing this B GST I said you
know what this is now he's doing some
comic relief
we've got shouts a crap game or craps
kind of doing the news right he's
reading the news the panel's reacting
right we all take this for granted now
but these two guys are doing this thing
they got this thing cooking and I turned
over to my family I said these guys need
me right I got a ghetto look I need to
do this so I said well how do you do
this without you know say in the middle
Z and crap they always tell their
stories about it they make it you but I
reached out to Z and I said you know Z
I'm checking out your show I think it's
great I said I'd like that you know try
out because I know you said a couple
people at the time I'd left PG st how do
I do that
so Z gets ahold of me we go back and
forth did he's doing an interview
process you want to make sure you know
you're not some crazy you know so he was
going back and forth were asking each
other questions right so out of nowhere
Here I am on a Sunday afternoon I'm
sitting here I believe it was I want to
say it was 20 he was definitely 2014
early 2014 my phone goes off and I see I
said wait a minute
that here is it easy you know you still
want to do this this podcast thing I
said absolutely and I think it he's you
know like we talked about you know we're
like let's get our dates together we'll
make something work out sitting with
cross we got stuff going on he's like
you still want to do this I write back
yes absolutely
he's saying all right be ready by 6:30
tonight I'm like oh [ __ ] no I never did
this before I'm like somebody give me a
microphone right you know so I'm
screaming that out the window the guy so
I get everything set up I go on there
and do the show and afterwards I get you
know I get some feedback from Z crap
gets old to me and they're like you know
you did pretty good I go well I go you
know you just butter on my roll what's
the deal hot he's like no listen we've
had people on the show and I always call
pulling a Walt Disney you sometimes you
have people on the show
and they love the show they love the
idea but just because you can buy a
microphone doesn't mean you should use a
microphone you know I'm saying so that's
the way it is sometimes so I said - I
said do it did I you know he's like
listen I'll let you know but I
definitely want to get you back on the
show
and I said alright that's bad I said
that is realistically the biggest
compliment you could do so time went by
but a week goes by all of a sudden I get
pinged again he's like you want to do
this I said yeah Danny he goes do you
want to do this regularly I said
absolutely
III comes and no people were doing a
little doom and gloom but I dug what I
saw in 2014 at e3 okay I like the
direction I saw they do at the time we
saw some new games coming out still and
so crap gets old to me says hey you want
to just do a one on one it seems like
you really liked it we'll do it on a
Wednesday night and it was just a
one-time thing just a post-show it's
funny how things kind of start like so
we're just doing one thing anyways that
become so that that one showed me a crap
do a two-hour thing on the review of III
becomes what we all know is Xbox nation
you know I mean in everything just kind
of built up and it kind of ramped up
into what we know today of course the
winner plays a role and and to be honest
with you it's been great you know it has
been absolutely wonderful the
community's fantastic yeah you know and
no kami runs like I said you go back in
the day Cognito when you go back to 2013
2014 realistically what was the console
wars and the way people were kind of
going at each other it was like I said
it was like when we were talked about
this offline everybody's kind of like
the old high school days right give each
other you throw a jab a jab come back
somebody could dodge the jab sometimes
you got hit in the face right but it was
what it was and then you know it kind of
evolved and I want to even bring it to
today and to say that what we are doing
today is a great day shoutout to n LG's
in the chat absolutely I mean we've got
BRAF in the chat you got crap in the
chat jay ponds salt the thing usually
these are all people that we all had our
stories of how we got into it why we
wanted to get into it we got the Lords
we got mooks we got everybody's here the
point of the matter is that now we can
still have our healthy opinions we can
still have our healthy like you don't
have to like what I like but what what
the point is is that sometimes and I'll
be honest with you like I came around
right I came around to a lot of
different games that I didn't think I
would like like I did not like Dark
Souls at all
now I had to watch that man play my son
but there's a different generation
watching people play games I'm not into
that but my son watches him he watches
his stream and he kind of kind of
watching that that's a yeah so I'm
eating and I'm watching and watch him
and he said look at him daddy he's
killing all the monsters with the big
heads first it was somewhere boom he was
in and he survived it and I said man I
can't have my son daddy play at that
werewolf and in the beginning everybody
has in blood-borne I said you know what
maduk is a true beast this game is not
for me but it's it's serious okay so
yeah I feel you on that about Dark Souls
just to get back in the game in a bit is
you know here's the reason I like it you
sit here and we talk about those ghosts
and goblins days you talk about the day
before the up up down down left right
left right before that when you only had
the three lives to get through contract
okay this is a game I call this the game
of games Dark Souls because let me tell
you just how much it is so people go
what the hell are you talking about if I
want to play with my friend in a co-op
session you have to play the game to
earn the Ember to call your friend yes
this is what I'm trying you can't just
hit two players start okay you need to
play the game get the right he earned
the fact to bring somebody in and help
you through a fight this is I'm saying
when I saw that that's when my eyes
opened up again I said wait a minute
wait a minute this game is something
unlike anything else I have right now in
my collection
it is but in the community in the dark
souls come and I'm not listen if you
don't like the game I don't like the
game that's fine absolutely but what I
want people to realize what this game is
it is you know you say
it's a gamers game you have to play it
yes to even bring a friend on board that
to me that's what I said
wait a minute getting me right now this
game is playing me it's making me do
something I didn't even think I had to
do singing my friends and Bob so that
being said that's what I'm saying about
opening our eyes and he forward right
free and you you know me listen I was I
was I related Dark Souls to a Paul
Abdullah for I did you full circle and
you just said it's like back in the day
high school like I equivalent a lot of
this stuff is it's like sports teams
right yes a lot of us you know yo you
Yankee Joe imagine or whatever team it
was and everybody just had that pride
yes sometimes I go a little too far but
at the end of the day you know sometimes
I remember getting to the age where I
mean King had the school be like I did I
used to be a Michael Jordan hater
whatever whatever and he was like who's
better than him like I could
realistically write it like he was just
winning with an offense she had to get
to that maturity that age to say you
know what right he's the best
like there's no you know exactly it's
just that maturation processing even
from sports and then for gaming you know
I'm saying and Nass was so cool and I
think like I'm so glad we did this
because a lot of people don't get a
chance to see that evolution from a lot
of our community and and people in boxes
and stuff like oh I wanted to say this
before because you know you mentions a
year and you know anxiety his problems
or whatever I reached out to me and
expressed my concern for him and also
you know this community we all have the
same mistress and I know he heard this
plenty of times we all fell in love with
the same thing in this gaming so at the
same essence of it is like I don't care
how you got to this point but you got to
this point and it was a gateway point
that we all had everybody had that same
epiphany moment that I can't live
without this so at what point
became a divide I don't care where you
game it I don't care if your game with
your cell phone you game in we are
brothers hurry so for it to become a
divide and become personal and attacks
and trying to separate no I'm trying to
unify and I want all the plan I want us
all to hold dealers in this room all
crap is in this room or mooches in this
room and we're all in the same room
talking about the same exact yeah that's
the commentary at the end of the day
it's gaming which unites us you know
they're like listen we all have our own
takes we all got our own different we're
not all gonna agree on everything it's
not a kumbaya situation but we have to
understand that yo we came we all love
this same thing that's right playing
video games and getting away from the
drama's of life that's our escape you
know right back to you Lord mooch you're
going right from that point and then you
said I'm with the channel like I said
you had you said the BG st expecting all
that stuff and then my question now is
like how did what was the birth of
crossfire it was the motivation in the
promotion from Zaire is he kept on
saying to me all the time he's like move
I don't know what the hell you're
waiting for will you please start a
channel so a lot of times you'll see you
know you see somebody they have their
they're born on date of when they
started their channel
I had the YouTube thing but it's at
their Idol doing nothing it was just so
right there's nothing so then he's like
listen he said you got people in the
chat right now on BG st you got these
mooch maniacs showing up right there
showing up outside the house he's like
why don't you see he said why don't you
start a show so easily I said listen
okay now look at the Lord right you like
this one the Lord only made seven days
dang right right according to the
Scriptures we have there and I'm looking
down like all right Monday's gone
Tuesday's this guy guys say these folks
Thursdays and I'm like all right so
there's Friday and I said to myself no
wait a minute I said you know Friday
used to be a night that when you're a
younger cat you're going off to the club
it's the snack you're making a stomach
good no I said maybe Friday's not gonna
work but I said you know what that's not
who I'm trying to reach right now you
got your collar pop then you going to
the audience I'm going for right now you
know listen that color pops coming back
by the way that's still coming back cut
so I said I know this gaming community
looks forward to the end of the week to
come home get their favorite drink get
something to eat and start gaming on
Friday night and there's nothing better
than that so I said all right listen
nobody's going for Friday let me see if
I can make Friday work so BAM there we
go and again it was Zaire and crap being
like you need to do this it's not a do
go to Jack your heart everybody said you
do that shooter McGavin and do it right
it's good so Friday has been a lot of
fun and I like it so I don't know I'm
not gonna say I'm a pioneer by no means
but my idea was a little bit different
so I done V GST did xbox nation and we
had set folks that came on every single
week it was the same panel I said you
know what I said the way for me to
express myself as I like a little debate
you don't need to the topics we even
even hit the topics at will meeting the
topics there's gonna be somebody on the
panel says mooch I like where you're
coming from but here's let me tell you
one of my oldest love let me tell you
why you're wrong okay the situation is
not all of us are gonna think the same
so I want it I've always done crossfire
where I have what I call my usual
suspects which is my crew that we all
have and then I try to bring on two
guests every week different and I think
that that's important and now that the
community is doing what we're doing
right now here on iron Lords podcast and
is we're it you know and we're expanding
everybody this is what's good Saab has
been on their Cognito you guys know that
when we get on we have fun and it's
because you don't have to come on and
agree with me as a matter of fact I
prefer you were free like me you are the
same in that regards because I'm the
same I don't like see me yes guy kind of
player I liked it a bit I like people to
challenge me I like people to say you
know what I didn't see it from that
perspective I mean and that's what
creates that healthy debate and when I
got on crossfire be
no me wait the a was it what I expected
right gonna be everybody going in a
circle been like oh I agree with you
that's right that's right no it's not
because if you agree with me there's
nothing to tune into right I mean I
can't make a public service announcement
get it over with 15 seconds this week so
I mean I realistically I want you guys
to discuss and like you say open up your
mind and let's talk about it let's you
know so that's where crossfire came from
and then last but not least I had a
meeting with crap and I said you know
the one thing I really really enjoy and
we were talking about this just before
the show started was I love morning
radio okay any of us that have gotten up
you take the bus to wait you go here put
your headset on right yeah that's right
that's what you listen to listen to talk
radio talk right so I said the crap I
said you know what I want to do I want
to do a morning show I wanted to do the
morning show and I think I think we're
all t'm utley gonna go back to mornings
eventually but with the schedule it was
just tough but I said let's do something
where we could take a little bit of like
a creative we could do a couple of skits
where we poke fun of Xbox we poke fun at
Sony we poke fun at the media we poke
fun of ourselves right we do the whole
thing I say let's do it with a little
bit of a higher production value and I
said let's give folks their Sunday
morning like just their gaming listen I
want to talk about gaming with a cup of
coffee does it always have to be with a
vodka straight up just have a cup of
coffee some gaming news and that's and
that's why I love how we did have this
great chemistry where we went right from
m-and-c right and if sometimes Luca
would do a 12 o'clock spot and then you
guys were going on at 1:00 so we got
something and like I said I think I miss
he's gonna come back to Sunday's
eventually but realistically that's what
kind of drove that was my passion for
morning radio you know so and here we
are today
yes and this is no I kind of bring this
to Nick yeah you know and that's how it
was born they do it is amazing started
fantastic stories and like I said I
think you guys don't get enough credit
for what you do I've been on a show it's
been fantastic also shut up your team
and you've got a nice panel we've
actually had like almost half your panel
and IOB at this boom that was a great
fine yes great signing I was
it was almost like literally like an
undrafted you know what I mean like a
people always sorry just boomer reached
out to me and he goes listen he goes uh
look he goes a lot of people point reach
out to you but I'd really like a chance
at this and so I said all right just say
where we did I said let me let me see
what the scary because I don't want to
have someone new come on the show and be
the ninth person in your hands you're
gonna get drowned out so I said listen
let's do this right let's get you on in
about three weeks he goes good that'll
give me enough time to get the right
know and we went back and forth I showed
him how people showed me a good
microphone good setup hook the man up he
did that he came on and he killed it so
I said you know what let's do it same
ways I hear he said I said let's do this
again in a couple of weeks it's still
your flavor see if it's something you're
digging back on in two weeks say you
know what you need to do you need to be
on here pretty much all the damn time
nice and the man is passionate dude
that's what he's writing me every day
guys he's writing me every day he's like
you know let me do this and should I do
that he's sending me sound bites do you
think this dude is legit he's into it as
passionately Jesus it resonates you can
you can complete and see it it is so
cool man like I said shout and if you
say well you got one more hop I don't
want to show you
it's crap yeah X PI Who am I missing
as you're ready Alan Walsh Alan Walsh
yes and clowned you've had two holes
he's a wholesome duty helps the
community out like when I was setting up
one of my fight to the stream a lot of
people don't know I did a stream where
you know the whole thing at one of my
one of my claim to fame early on back in
the day was the whole rocket League /
soccer cars
writen so right when soccer cars finally
made its way to Xbox I reached out I
can't remember what show I was on I
think I I believe it or not I think I
came into one of your chats when you had
you had Phil on or Aaron on and in the
chat was Major Nelson said I want and
Major Nelson in the chat I said
something along the lines of I said hey
major
why don't we stream soccer cars the week
after it launches he writes back right
away
let's do it mooch I said holy [ __ ] I'll
be damned so like
like hanging out with Larry that's like
the he's a tough dude to get a hold on
so I'm like all right so so we ended up
setting it up and shout out the clowns a
shout out to uh inferno they got
together help me out because we didn't
have the streaming thing that we have
now a mixture right right all they're
all these people in chat to come through
which we couldn't ultimately do at the
end but I sled inferno and clowns
yes diligently to help me get Larry's
voice through on the broken so we still
did the broadcast with Larry but I was
kind of doing a now you know I asked
Larry the question after he would
respond to me while we were playing the
game and I would then tell the audience
what he said as verbatim as I could
while playing a video game
right that was all about difficult and
sweating to death bags out the clown
shout if the whole crew barium and four
guys recorded they actually took
affiliates as well we got allowed to
take affiliates in a building right now
an LG brat all that much a priest talks
for hours but I was looking to see all
the iron Lords podcast and I saw that
you guys go to about 2 hours and 20
minutes today's going about four hours
and EJ listen I'm not throwing those
white gloves in the bushes
right now I do understand that you guys
get off on me and add it going at each
other we don't really normally do that
in their boots lasting obviously we off
most of us here in the pan on the Lord's
table are from New York so know the
meaning of your name to be one thing so
we're just gonna clarify yes you know
what here's the thing I've always felt
ok and I do this to this day you know a
mooch you look it up it's someone who
you know just kind of like leeches it
takes [ __ ] you know and a
here's the way I looked at it back in
the day you know when we used to hang
out let's say I would go over to Cognito
spot right I go over to soft spot there
King I say listen I said you guys are
getting together having a hangout we're
all what we're 18 to 21 let's say we're
21 for the conversation because we talk
about having some beers in the fridge
and your big move I'm gonna bring you to
bring no beer and I'm like you got 12 of
them in there so listen up people right
so some people would actually grab a
beer from you back in the day right and
then they would walk off and go hang out
or go dude I would hang with you all day
if someone come up there says hey can I
get that cigarette you give them the
cigarette and the dude just leaves with
you now you have a conversation you
gotta you gotta respect that so this is
still right thank you yes yeah like you
just open up my eyes
there's correct ways to be a mooch
incorrect
people I love listen it was all about
bringing the entertainment right even
now right the big thing in the
communities like you know you Mucha game
but if I move your game let me be real
with you I don't just go thanks for the
game no shout out the big e two three
one six get me monster monster world
right Masterson I didn't know who big he
was he heard me say I wanted to move
that sends me the code and I saw meet
him play through the game 50 60 65 hours
that's what's up and that's what it's
all about if you go to mooch okay you
hang with the cigarette kind of example
right the minute somebody takes a game
or takes a singer takes the sandwich
from you and gets leaves you don't want
nothing to do with that dude true that
goes to alert shout out to Cole Cole you
a fraud i gifted you give to somebody a
game and they don't play
finish you off with the last segment
which is yes every guest yeah yeah top
five or franchises of all man that is
that is difficult it is difficult um
let's go let's go
let's make this let's get because we got
we got a lot because showing it to we
got a lot of to do real quick I'm gonna
say and these are just because I I
didn't know I didn't know you were gonna
ask that but I'm gonna throw a little
bit ditch know we're new in there okay
vintage I'm gonna go with The Legend of
Zelda everybody's gotta listen listen
that's like when you ask people in film
you know you're gonna hear the Godfather
come out of Casablanca Legend of Zelda
you gotta pay respect with respect to do
that was a game that opened a lot of
people's eyes so there's one okay so
let's put that out there let's put this
out there Castlevania all of them
because realistically that was the
platforming game that set me straight
that I was like and I still think you
know if I was ever in the boot that I
was able to make a decision
when you talk all these people out I
didn't particularly care for rise you
know the game that came out this
generation I wasn't a huge fan I think
was thinking wrong with it I think it
just needed a little bit more but if you
take rise and put some of the
Castlevania esque right give that man a
whip on a chain and a ball right give
this you know that is that's the kind of
game that really got me in thrall back
as a kid I love those types of games
that was how I got into the platform and
the whole nine loved the Simon Belmont
the whole immaculate thing right list of
course that's where their true zombie
like darkness I did not so shame on me
but number three I have not see where
you guys where you guys see that I'm you
know what I'm doing my my arm hair just
went up my moose senses I'm sensin attic
sending me a code in a few minutes but I
right if you really want to know
realistically I would say the gears
franchise of course okay and then I've
got to give credit where credit's due
while I'm saying and I'm leaving some
great titles out so please don't judge
me Oh Dark Souls because that's changed
the way that I look at the way games are
played and I will say this much from the
beginning okay from the very beginning
all the way up through the GameCube okay
back on the PlayStation and where we are
today I'm gonna leave credit where
credit's due Resident Evil still holds a
very very warm spot in my heart and I'm
talking way back okay go now go back to
your old podcast because boom is
accepting now he's yes boom listen and
that's what's so great - you wanna talk
about that link that's something that
means later because listen everybody
else is down on it he's gone
listen that game can that game could
suck I can't wait for it I'm excited as
hell you put zombies in a game there all
right there we go there's my five I'm
gonna go off top man that was impressive
that out though delve in let's get it
because we got a lot a lot of topics
let's get into it so on last week's poll
results are in the people have spoken
with the plethora of consumer friendly
services that Xbox Live's provides do
you think Xbox Live should adopt a tier
level pricing model the winner at 58% in
a fairly convincing three-way ILP poll
is the yes we want game pass
incorporated into the xbox live
subscription group coming in at second
place at 23% was the no not it less
motor play online multi-player is free
at the base level group and at third
place with a close 9 percent of the vote
was I don't care until I see these more
exclusive games group thanks all the
lords who participated in the poll Lord
mooch what do you think about combining
or incorporating that subscription
that's what the fan scene one yeah I'm
also in that camp I think that it should
but I liked how you put the question
earlier in Fi and I didn't see the poll
so pardon me but realistically I think
that there should be tears
there are certain people that let's get
to the tears before we talk about the
combining of the two the tears is good
for the different you know listen since
we are I like to joke around with this
we are in the generation of options
folks okay so that's what we're doing
here if you want to drive with the
windows down in the air-conditioning on
that's what we're doing we would have
got slapped silly in the 80s but right
now okay but right now people are doing
that and that's fine so if you want to
let people make a decision on their
tears and say I just want to play online
with my friends but I don't need these
games with gold okay take me out of
there let me just play and maybe that's
either gonna be one that it'll never be
on the house but it'll be like a twenty
dollar deal right and then it'll be or
maybe a twenty-five dollar deal than
fifty for the whole thing and I think
that you should give those options this
by yourselves giving people those
because a lot of people and me included
I know a lot of people just go on every
first of the month and they go pick up
this download nobody wants to play super
meatboy when you got this kind of lineup
coming up but they gave it away so you
take it right you wanna scoop a potato
sound of course I want potato sell like
nice boy see your backlog this growing
girl I just like looking at that whole
big stack of games are giving us
sometimes like you take it because it's
there but realistically there's a lot of
people that if you said instead of $60 a
year what if I charge you 30 and you
don't have to deal with playing with
Mickey Mouse adventures next month
you're okay with that right you could
deal with it so I do think that that's
fine but realistically and I wanted to
say I'm gonna save my my my idea my
thought of what Microsoft is doing I did
mention it on crossfire but I want to
wait till we get to Xbox of all access
absolutely but it wouldn't hurt them to
have another option when they take game
pass and they take live which really
and and combine them for a little bit of
a lower price give the customer a break
that's inevitable it's coming oh god oh
what'd you call it is next-level gaming
all right what's inside here is cucumber
ginger lemon all right and that's that
Alka lines the water and it purifies
your body cleans out your kidneys and me
on xbox you understand I'm cursed Laden
but my kid watch the show it would not
be any for the little Lords we
appreciate you Lord saw what is going on
in the world with this Xbox Live what is
going on what's going on is that over
the Wii over the past week there in
Gamescom windows central speculating and
everybody else pretty much did the same
that Microsoft was on the verge of
announcing a new service called Xbox all
access would allow you to subsidize the
purchase of an Xbox one S or X system
while combining the gamepad service as
well as Xbox Live into one monthly
payment much like they did at the end of
the 360 era where they subsidized I
forgot which 360 it was probably the
smallest GPS who was the end of the
average again the error um in order to
give you Xbox why basically Trojan horse
the whole thing in Xbox Live is your
house and I think this it still hasn't
been confirmed by Microsoft but enough
infos out there that it seems like it is
a real thing they just probably weren't
ready to announce it at Gamescom - far
as we know got to cut you first we know
it's the US market only at this point is
what the rumors suggested at this point
the rumors suggesting is only US market
to start off with I mean I guess we are
their test market so let's see how it
goes here before they move it else
we're um but yeah like mucho saying this
is another option that they're giving
people as a way to onboard into the Xbox
ecosystem and for them I think it is
another way the Trojan horse game pass
into everything because for them I think
game path is everything going forward
every distantly folded into if we look
at other now things that they announced
during games come are then they released
the game pass app well yes the surface
doesn't seem like much but if you think
about it why would you release a game
pass app when you have game pass
integrated into the Xbox app already
it's because right in class is gonna be
the star correct ventually so this is
just a way of getting people into the
ecosystem without you know doing it
painfully upfront buying a $500 or $200
system and what's the point what's the
point of entry far is d because they
have to like the s and the X right
monthly payments looking like so the S
subscription is looking like they're
talking about twenty two dollars a month
which would make that about a six or
seven dollar a month
investment towards the the actual
console itself right figure you figure
live over the course of the two years is
about 120 dollars no and game pass over
the course of a year is a hundred and
twenty dollars right so it breaks down
to about $10 a month for $10 a month for
for game pass for the year and then five
dollars a month or for live for the year
do whatever you're paying you know the
seven dollars or whatever you're paying
for the console the same thing so and
then for the X the X option it's gonna
be about thirty five a month so that's
you know again twenty dollars above the
the ten and five dollar breakdown for
the Xbox four game pass and whatnot for
the X come at the end of the two years
the way they're talking about it is that
the at the end of the two years the
system is yours um and you can choose to
cancel or the subscriptions or not if
you want so if you break down the
numbers the math you you stand to save a
little bit a couple of bucks over the
course of of the two-year contract again
it's an option for people who don't have
the resources to pay for all this stuff
up front
ryan wanna maybe
test out the ecosystem I'm sure they
they're gonna have to implement some
sort of way for people to get out of it
if they don't want to continue it would
not it is what it is um I think it's a
great option I think again if is talk
about difficulty getting Xbox consoles
into homes this is another way to get
that and again what they really want is
for you to be invested in game past and
solution form whatever platform you're
on so I think it's great I think it's
great all right so here we are you know
this uh Xbox Live all-access thing going
on so low much I know you would hold on
to some thoughts about this so let's get
you right into the mix what did you
think about this announcement this rumor
hasn't been officially unveiled by Xbox
but rights are pretty strong shout out
to a Jeff Gordon from Windows Central
friend of the show and also um I want to
shout out Tom Warren who also was the
one I believe who tweeted it before that
something like this rumors was coming
down a pipe so Lord mooch Xbox
all-access where are you at with this
so Xbox all-access is is for me for me
it's it's not it's not for me because
we've already I'm already there right
we've already got the ex in hand we're
playing we're enjoying right now but
this is a great thing and where I want
to add the value is now we're reading on
the top layer you got to kind of peel it
back a little bit and look a little
deeper to what Microsoft is thinking and
me and x5 four four eight we were kind
of talking about this on crossfire where
if you can have something that's
consumer friendly and something that's
good for the good for the business too
you know to me and that's what
Microsoft's trying to do here they're
really trying to balance the scales so
hear me out
game pass okay as it currently stands
and I understand it's getting good press
right now yeah but game past needs to do
a few things right now to make it what
we think it can be and that is day and
date third party games now everyone says
that but they don't explain it to you
okay I realize we're not gonna get GTA 6
in there I understand that that ain't
coming okay they don't need that money
they got their own money good when you
have games like Metro Exodus okay
or you have games that came out like the
evil within to which is three and a half
weeks after it came out dropped half
price okay
these are games that Microsoft needs to
be able to go to the table with a
bargaining chip and said we need to have
your game
in game past day and date now let me
explain that doesn't hurt the
PlayStation consumer it doesn't hurt the
PC consumer and it does not hurt the
consumer that is not in game past it's
an Xbox fan it's an option for people
that are already paying a $10 a month
subscription and feel like they have
something okay worthy of keeping that
subscription now you might say well how
they gonna do it the only way Microsoft
can do it is by showing these
third-party companies and publishers
okay that they have the butts in the
seats okay now how do you do that here's
how you do it
your shove game passed down our throat
in a very consumer friendly way and Xbox
all-access if this does end up being
true and come to fruition right with the
22 or $35 a month option depending on if
you want the S or the X is going to come
to your home for 2021 is a $35 plus
shipping and handling to your home with
game pass now the minute you hit accept
and you download that you're now a
number at Ally from Microsoft and that
is where you're gonna see that game pass
right now is gaining some ground but
it's not substantial enough it is not
substantial enough to go to the
bargaining table and talk to Bethesda
and say when you come out with your new
game it's got to be a game Paks are
gonna go to hell I do but once you take
all these people that are now gonna go a
la carte and do it this way and don't
say it's not gonna work of course it's
gonna work because anybody on Christmas
right now if this does come true you're
telling me that a parent for $35 okay
can have their kid wake up Christmas
morning and have right have an X under
the tree a hundred plus games with some
great third-party support right now and
Xbox Live to play with their friends the
minute they open that box that is very
consumer friendly it's gonna be it's
gonna be like a tidal wave this
Christmas and number two Microsoft now
has millions of more people that they
can show these publishers that they have
people they have butts in the seats that
is how you can get and you know
futuristic evil within three okay or
maybe a metro Exodus what that deck
games gonna be gorgeous but guess what
it's not gonna do great it's coming out
right in between Anthem
all these other great games that are
coming out like realistically Metro
would do great in game pass but that's
oh but but right now the Metro folks if
this lords panel right now we weren't
actually the publishers we'd be like
we're not doing that no I want to make
the $60 per sale at Target Walmart
everywhere but if I know that
Microsoft's gonna give me a cut every
time somebody hits that download button
mm-hmm now you're talking when you show
me that 10 million people have game past
now my ears are open because there's no
percentage of people that are gonna just
download it for no other reason just to
say that I can cuz I paid for game pass
and they throw it in the bushes and I'm
gonna explain because my time line with
ridiculous Microsoft took the baby into
it off the roof I've never seen so many
Sony fans in terrible fear in my whole
life I mean I'm talking about terrible
fear of the fact that they're the
precipice of doing something phenomenal
the reason why I say at this point it's
it's it's not gonna be as viable why
it's not gonna be as viable as some may
say I want it for the next generation
going forward don't push these systems
but that scarlet I go laughs all axis of
scarlet
exactly but these systems is coming now
if you control your horse - scarlet
though let's say and another hard day's
system the the Trojan horse system the
system that you can pack ride the cloud
streaming system where you can get all
that stuff because you're not gonna sell
a system at a loss right you want to
actually make some form of profit these
numbers that people are throwing around
I absolutely see no profit margin being
made for Microsoft off the system
at mall you want to lease you know when
you saw I don't we buy cell phones and
if we purchase the cell phone flat out
we're good but if we do these little
plans you don't notice that you actually
paying a little bit more so you're right
max off is not profiting off of this
it's not a be that's why I'm doing it in
bushes because y'all keep playing with
these numbers like somebody sat in the
boardroom it's like when I can see them
making a profit off of the hardware
because they don't make hardware for
free and they're not trying to give it
to you for free they wanna make a little
something off it because we give you a
heads up so listen if I give anybody
something ahead of time I want ten cents
on the dollar that's I'm gonna make my
money but they want to make some form of
profit so don't look at this I see 49.99
for the X something like that exceed
that I can see that 35 for the S I can
see that but that $22 that everybody I'm
throwing $22 in the [ __ ] and I'm
calling $22 in the bushes hardcore so
don't those for that yo get that out of
your head don't yes $22 is not realistic
at all
$22 might be for the scarlet well yeah
we got a og in a chat real quick I gotta
I gotta say he's making a good point he
wants to talk to King he said hallway
doesn't make a company money he was like
that has been how things worked in the
past he said they make it up with myself
when his services so the whole thing is
his whole point was like engagement
engagement numbers I know he wants game
passing xbox live in your house I know
he wants Xbox Live on your phone you
know your tablet I know he wants game
pass on your phone with your tablet
he doesn't care where you game he just
wants you to game on his platform listen
to the king king i want to mention the
kingdom one thing also shout-out to uh
what is the next level game in there and
right he's 100% right with the software
but let me just let me just make some
dollars and cents for you with the
hardware to within the 22 and the 35
here's the thing the minute you take it
to use a car for example you buy a 50
thousand dollar car the minute you sign
your name that cars twenty five thousand
dollars you're still paying like it's
$50,000
hear me out yeah let's get to what we're
talking about with the hardware every
single day that goes by they're getting
these components cheaper and cheaper
these numbers on the third let's just
use the Xbox one one the $35 the X
you're 35 dollars when you map that out
it basically comes to the cost of the X
right right chip so hear me out
legitimately over the course of two
years they are making money on you on
the hardware because they are hurting
this thing cheaper as the day goes on
but you're still pay for it like it's a
$500 console so they are still making
money that this is the thing that people
got to realize so a lot of people that
were anti this I use it they were kind
of giving shade yesterday time yeah well
yeah you saw you saw right those folks
that were doing that they were saying
wait a second this they were saying that
that's a negative what I'm saying is
those people that were throwing shade
we're actually correct from Microsoft is
making that money cuz let's be honest no
matter who is smiling at you when you do
business when you hand them over that
$20 to make it some money on you so
they're gonna make money on this and
that's where it holds water first of all
with the original G saying is 100% right
you know Cheryl he's right they want you
right sting was he's right you want to
make the money off of the software not
realistically they are making money with
the hardware because as that value to
use to diminish they're still charging
you top Tom price so ultimately it's a
win for the consumer because it becomes
a monthly forget about it $35 that we
all paid 35 for something listen if you
have HBO go and Hulu BAM you're already
right so boom you already there so what
I'm saying to you is like people that I
said this years ago with the ala carte
nonsense if you like cut the cord cut
the cord like don't cut mine okay
attack and if you cut it splice it okay
I loved my cord my boy is this so like
the matter of fact is I think everybody
in this panel in the hardcore whether
they're in favorite or not the hardcore
gamer is not really gonna buy into this
right this is really not for us but it's
a Frankie for the mass public I want to
get a deuce often because definitely
addict I'm very curious about this RAM
you know I believe what do you feel
about this announcement you know they
are looking at the software I think that
they plan on making money from that last
time I checked the original Xbox H if I
remember correctly they make like $35
every unit that sounds about right yes
so even if they you know because if you
if you do the math they're losing $20
for two years of all this services
they so they're still making I don't
know about the X I assume that it would
be around the same I don't think $20
even if you take off what they make off
the X the S or even the original Xbox
which they're you know they're not going
to do the original Xbox but those I
don't think they're making any money
they're losing money they might not be
gaining as much money from the console
but I think what they're really looking
at you know okay we'll give them a $20
discount for two years we'll get a
customer that is locked down yeah
someone buys a console you might get
them for one service you might Xbox Live
or game passed you might get one of them
sometimes you'll get to depending
depending if they enjoyed the trial but
when you get these people locked in for
two years for all three they're paying
pretty much all three of these services
and you're just taking the $20
difference and you're making more money
in the long run you're getting these
people to consistently stay on these and
after I used to do dish after that after
that ends up they'll pay the extra money
for gold and a game pass just to keep
what they're used to for the last two
years that's right yeah no fair enough I
saw I want you to jump in because I guys
like to see so what you got bad with
so thing I just think again it is
another option like mooch said I
completely agree like over the course of
the two years and they're gonna be
making money off of you any anybody who
ever think there was a lot of arguments
going like King was saying like people
pissed off that one happens it it's
drawing people into into these long
contracts that they not gonna be able to
when in the never in the history of ever
have you paid for something over the
course of a long period of time and paid
less for it it doesn't happen
the plan is punishment for not having
the money up front let's get to the
photos so what happens if you don't come
in on this one point right here because
this is not for you guys this hour with
bad credit that said don't don't listen
to Moose Pig you go finesse this one you
can shop and slap you with those white
gloves you need good credit going in
alright this is not for that that that
student who has the 540 credit school
think he's gonna know where this slide
[Laughter]
that Microsoft has to have because is in
place there has to be something on the
account level and on the hard hardware
level to prevent you from if you try to
finesse and get out long back you know
don't say get out
this is gonna happen they're gonna send
you a nice cordial email saying that
they have not received your payment for
that month yet if payment does not come
through you're gonna see your service is
stopped and you're gonna get a bill in
the mail for the entire rest of what you
owe on that console down people are say
this is some of the stuff I'm seeing on
Twitter
this is predatory young kids in a bed
I've heard young there's no young kid
that has a credit card I've heard the
argument that this puts poor people in a
position where they think they can
afford this and they can't listen if
you're poor and by the definition of
poor meaning you there are certain basic
necessities that you have a problem
getting in this life then the least of
your problems is how you gonna get next
box one of your problem is or how am I
gonna play this game like like anything
else if you have you know whatever like
18 euros 19 or 20 year-olds it you know
get you get access to a credit card your
first credit card would not this is
stuff that parents still need to be
monitoring when I got my first credit
card I thought it was slick I got my
first credit card and I went right to KB
toy stores and I bought a PlayStation
with like an extra control that was my
first PlayStation I got everything and
my dad was like oh how's that
PlayStation I like what are you talking
about you think you know I got the
letter saying anybody like these things
need to be monitored by parents and if
you're not doing that like there's a
problem with you absolutely you're so
much fun watching you know the whole
thing I mean this thing let's be like
I'm gonna shout out a lord or dam a
color we had a head of Xbox Live on last
week and he
Kanna gave us some foreshadowing that
either some pricing or some change so
shout out to him and actually please
watch that LP if you missed it and um
you know if the whole thing is I think
this was right on time you know it's a
great super consumer friendly move we
can't ignore that right you know as far
as this point we have to say Microsoft
just dominating as far our services and
it's all about engagement for them they
want people on xbox live like normal
true saying they want Buxton and C they
want to show these devs look this is
where the gamers are they're here
they're playing that and again my edits
again is more chance for spending so my
only question is obviously the
availability though because at the end
of the day the rumor is out right now
but from what I hear I want to shout out
some good friend Jes Gordon we shot at
you out on Xbox who ran in my dudes from
what I hear this is Microsoft Store only
now if it remains that I have a problem
me too at the end of the day look at the
amount of stores in the United States
it's not that they have now unless they
offer it online or the other magic word
which I don't know if it's gonna happen
is retail but the problem I see with
that is what does game stop you know
target have to benefit from offering
this service like they're not getting a
cut right to me they've gotten with the
reason they would do it this time he's a
lot of people will go in here it will
probably go depending on you know what
kind of credit you have you have any
kind of down payment or anything like
that and a lot of people are probably
gonna pick up a game along physical that
you could put aside your box game this
is just extra this is options but this
is not for a person that only has thirty
five dollars left in his budget in order
for this thing like I'm excited I think
it's great you know I'm saying I think
it's another option I'm just thinking
about myself like I you know we make
offers make pretty decent money so at
the end of dealer I I back and buy a
galaxy phone if I want out right but
sometimes you don't want that upfront
right right you just wanted to you know
what I don't need to put nine eight
honey and these phones this is how my
brain works already got the finesse and
this is this is sad but what my fear is
somebody's getting somebody's credit
card and they ordered his Xboxes working
on ways to don't allow that to happen
the serial number yeah it's gotta
remember that thing with the PlayStation
2 and use able to get it from
Blockbuster mm-hmm one thing we gotta
give credit when Microsoft like I get
shout out to Lorne the color that we had
like no as far as security protocols and
the things that they do as far as that
they're pretty strong we haven't had any
type of breeches kind of like you know
was it the ps3 everywhere was like the
source code was like at the front of the
door and people were just you know I
just want to see if they can get it out
to more some things outside of the
Microsoft Store and the other thing I
want to see is how its enforced right
we've gotta see what happens if you
don't pay
and that your credit what's gonna happen
is first off though I guarantee you
they're gonna require some kind of
credit card upfront to put on the file
they'll run that credit card which you
can always you know cancel the credit
card right and if you if that doesn't
work they'll send you an email or bill
saying how much you have left and if you
don't pay they'll hit you credit that's
literally all they can do that's
literally all so what if we have options
we'll be cool - let's just say do you
think they'll offer amass this little
much do you think they will offer a
situation let's say you're paying your
35 a month you're getting X right I
don't think there'll be a situation
where let's say you come up with tax
time you come across some bread okay so
now do you think you can just pay it off
like a credit card bill and get them out
of your life I think actually announced
there's gonna be interest like because
listen because at the end of the two
years that end up being pretty much a
wash anyways you can go ahead if you
come into some excellent usually you
come in and let's extra bread just go
ahead for that or do they may let you
try to pay your contract yeah you just
pay the car you can pay the contract in
full of you know discounters need now
here's the thing and I don't want to you
know segue into your next subject you
know cagney know but realistically we
got to talk about it since it doesn't
pertain to all axes cuz look King is
what King is actually laughing about
what she's right - okay it's all the
nonsense that he's reading right now you
know I think Xbox missed a golden
opportunity by not talking about this
while they had the entire hashes
themselves at Gamescom because right
look at what we're doing right now just
the five of us alone we've come up with
six different scenarios the chats going
off on a tangent Internet's going wild
people like I'm gonna have a district
court staff at this track
that's the most exciting part about this
is if this is successful do they push it
day and date with the new consoles
coming if I were a buddy there's a good
chance that it's on the next consoles
but here's the thing with to muchas
point I hear what you say it would have
been the most perfect yes all right but
the only issue is for my understanding
because it's us only didn't one
announced it their systems in Germany at
this point right now right but I think
they're just not ready for that market
and they want to debut it here where
they have the Microsoft stores they have
the footprint from what I understand it
kind of got out when it they weren't
ready not like if they did it during an
inside Xbox show like people said throw
tomatoes at that's disrespectful if you
have that conference in another country
and you start talking about features for
them we've got for us I think
realistically when you have that much
media attention and you've got so many
people watching cuz there's nothing from
games come until possibly what III
nothing
why now here's what's gonna end up
happening so they're gonna miss that
staged event right there is pax West
they could probably do it that's true
but realistically will miss that a big
stage and you're gonna have a bunch of
people doesn't be a bunch of people just
taking this information and running with
it in saying like not factual propaganda
but isn't that the best part of how this
internet and is this is just the Twitter
and all the stuff is working we're doing
the legwork for them not just in the
water and they're seeing the temperature
of the room do you really want to see if
Sony dude is real these Sony dudes heads
are exploding right now because
PlayStation is not gonna offer this you
got you if you don't have your five
hundred four hundred dollars up front
you're not getting one right but if
Microsoft just told you you walk in the
store with your Social Security card at
$35 and you came home with the service
in the package how many people is gonna
be on Xbox how does this switch the
narrative from I don't have five right
now because I actually gotta buy milk
and diapers for my kids but I nuke at
this thirty five dollars though you busy
saying like Xbox athlete you need it
need to have another event around the
holidays yeah so that's a possibility
good going on anybody saw if you got
anything on the table for me like real
quick something to move mentioned I
there was speculation before Gamescom
that actually shadowed the Tomb Raider
and Metro would be day and day on game
path it wasn't completely debunked but
much like the the announcement of this
much like the announcement of the the
league controller to that sort of got
pushed back this is still a possibility
it was a rumor so nobody said it's
absolutely not happening so they might
be a little too close for for Tomb
Raider I know a lot of people already
pre-order Tomb Raider would suck of the
HIPAA Denning games on that already had
those conversations that could be in the
works and secondly my overall point to
this I think this is just all a Trojan
horse for game pass even live I think at
some point live just didn't fold it into
game pass and it Salim what's our
favorite word again baby they want you
engage with game fast that's what they
want it I wanted like people are going
in on this like you know I've seen this
is the craziest thing that Microsoft's
ever done that I've seen get this much
attention over nothing
looks like at the end of the day people
like oh you know there's not a market
for this people were there they're
acting like this hasn't been done for
like 15 years there's renesis
there's figure HUD there act like they
didn't do it last gen was like you know
you go through something like those
other ones you're probably paying like
60 70 dollars for one time because what
you're doing you're paying like $40 and
you paint like 30 dollars in interest
every we're all forgetting this is
strictly strictly an option listen if
we're all in right we're all out the
game we're all out of the game we all
pull out you pull out your Samsung you
pull out your iPhone
I don't care nor need to know if you're
paying that $45 a month for that phone
or if you plunk down $900 Bethel me all
I'm looking at is I might get a nice
phone it's an option it shouldn't affect
anybody at all I mean that doesn't you
know what I mean I mean I don't you know
like I just want to point out it's not
like like even like someone like you
know if I anticipate it I could save up
money between now and the next-gen
console comes out I could still get a
day one but if you look at it for this
standpoint is long right now we have we
have no thoughts of interest because
that that hasn't been linked if there's
any interest right right now so we know
but official to you to do this even if
you can pay it all up front because
you're not even say you're not even wait
you're saving money in any way as long
as you want all three of those services
the Xbox the game pass and xbox live
which almost everyone here has Xbox Live
at least like you're saving $20 so
you're technically saving money by
paying off that's I don't think I've
ever seen that and I it's like I I agree
with King I don't think that's gonna be
the case I think there's gonna be some
type of
Oh friendly wood bro I think that their
number one thought process right now is
we might take even at the ticket which I
don't even think they will they might
not make as much money off the consoles
as they normally would right but they're
still making as long as they're not
making a negative I don't think they
care because they're gonna take a little
cut off their consoles but they're going
to broaden the horizon when it comes to
game pass you're gonna have millions of
people probably that's on game past I
wouldn't a bit on game pass they're
gonna be tweeting it like I think that's
their bigger picture they're not
carrying up a total $20 they lose their
wanting the overall perception that
everyone has the long I just want to say
this last thing on it I love the fact
that they're losing because you get all
the concealing stuff you go do this from
a position of winning you do the eye
gouging the groin punching the air
pulling the position of understand if
they're not willing to get dirty that's
not a company I'm willing to stand
behind I want you to pull here I want
you to punch people in the throats I
want you to get in there and win and
these dudes is going for the jugular
with de telling you we're bundling our
systems we're bundling all our services
we want to get you in right now right
those numbers is gonna shoot up himself
for the next-gen man and that yeah and
at the end of the day competition as we
all know is give you been around long
enough to understand competition is good
to get more benefits
let's more cuz we beat that thing to
death yo Lord addict man Gamescom let's
go so
I wanted to really you know gangs
conscious hat and a lot of xbox got a
lot of feedback over the you know when
it comes to okay but they got a lot of
feedback over their Xbox so I just want
to make this you know pretty sure ins
because obviously I don't want to run
over to too much lately
do you think that Microsoft is the
reason that they're failing and areas
such as Oda the reason that they're
failing in areas such as you know
anywhere out of the United States they
don't take anything else seriously but
III like do you think that maybe because
I mean let's me wrote games Khan is
actually bigger than III but they don't
even really do anything at e3 games long
they don't go to Paris game show they
don't go to tokyo game show pretty much
they don't have really presents in any
of these do you think they do you think
that might be one of the reasons that
they're losing worldwide and what's your
thought on the inside Xbox no doubt
let's start with Lord mucho noisy I'm
not saying this yeah I mean as far as I
said this last week I'll say it again
Gamescom is turned into nothing more
than a 350,000 foot traffic arcade right
now there's there's I mean God block
they could make this what it what it was
was it used to be the second coming of
III yes there's no more announcements
the announcements that are made or stuff
that we've already heard about for weeks
or a bundle we don't care about inside
Xbox is what it is you know I mean we
kind of got to talk about that I don't
think you know if you want a great
inside Xbox on an A through F scale the
best one we've seen is a c-minus I mean
it is right and I'm not saying they
shouldn't do it but I mean realistically
here's where I'm at with inside Xbox
people write me all the time hey MOOC
you're gonna be watching or checking out
inside Xbox I'm at the point right now
if I can I will but I certainly am not
moving anything in my schedule for I'm
gonna say it's affiliate advice I should
have right that's all you miss party is
law ricardinho told me that morning Matt
I did they wrote they moving different
than they usually
I was like its Gamescom and then you
know Nelson's talk about and they got
the little sign it was trolling they
really are at this point they're
trolling all of us and realistically
like I always joke around like one of my
favorite employees that Microsoft has is
actually a see bongos but I give
Malaysia I love them great dude but
realistically they don't they don't give
that man the right platform I mean do
you see him they literally brought he
went from the UK over to Germany just to
show off some Xbox socks I'm like what
the hell you doing the corner over there
I think that stupid thing they need to
throw that in the eighth row inside Xbox
and consolidated they need to make it
shorter they need 45 minutes I don't yet
scored it rich let's reach use that
money wisely okay
stop having any people on there only
that needs to be longer it's like III or
games call if you wanna make like an
hour different yes III is different but
I agree with movement it's gotta be boom
boom boom trailer trailer in announcer
bill now get the man stopping like right
now this is no disrespect when I go
shopping with my daughter's we're in the
store right when I go with my son
I see the impatience in his eyes he's
like your daddy let's get it let's go
let's go yep when I was a kid now I walk
through the mall to use Kings example
like I'm sitting there every mall now
he's got couches the chairs in the
middle
I gotta get I got my list in my head I
know what I gotta do I gotta get out
right and you're right my son when it
comes you go to shop when your son you
sounds like are we leaving yet oh my god
or a thing where I get out of here
you know we parked the car next to the
last door so you get the hell out of
there no the only person who didn't know
we're the same when you said that my
eyes open I said this is exactly what I
like we're listening you get back to it
these are two hours they're bringing the
dev out the devas coming out hanford him
don't speak English so we're all like
and I'm not talking about the Germany
thing like when they had the gentleman
come on for the the war the new Walking
Dead games okay
this was the one man was that hard to
watch I almost felt like I committed a
crime and in some boots what you gotta
do in your penance is watch this who
talked about how he's making the game
and as I'm sitting there I just had that
squid face sound like why am i doing
this to myself no I'm like why are you
doing this to your customers we don't
care and when they did that whole thing
you loved that part where they spent
like 15 minutes telling you how they
made the arcade you want to talk about
the worst of the inside Xbox is the
worst of the worst I swear to God was
when they did the state of decay to the
people trying to break out of that like
like they made that like double action
ahead mark summers with a microphone
listen I Got News for you right forehead
that's for all you old-timers out there
all right he has a double dare sect
rally and then when they were done and I
thought it was done I tweeted I was like
thank god that's done then Larry Kazan
here and now we did it with the Xbox
staff husband Oh
like Lucas says not like this like I
can't defend that it's not like I was
like this is just the whole thing was
just like I think inside Xbox definitely
need to be like direct
make it 45 minutes make it short get the
info you want to show me bundles show me
the bundles keep Larry's blown home
man I can't take but he keeps like old
me he brings class to it that's the van
of the situation listen that's his snake
that's his joint this is late nobody's
wearing white gloves like Larry cuz buds
got behind listen has to be convinced at
the end of the day has listen I want to
be very clear though I am happy that it
exists I want to be very clear like I
don't want it to completely go away I
like that we get some information
although it feels more like a marketing
product placement chill right now at
this point shortly joint there was some
positive we got the pub g 1.0 unofficial
we got my master chief collection that
was a big deal than people thought
collection ingame pass i know uh what
you call love would you care for the
state of the case intuitive at least
they had today bring back going on you
know say and a huge one for me person
was the almost a supermassive games they
had that uh whatever it's called mana
made it's a three-part series right and
that's from like the Unto Dawn kind of
style and I like that concept
who's gonna live who's gonna like the
horror stuff but you're the pacing is
awful too much with the cringy jokes and
let's get to the elephant in the room
what's up with those bundles man I know
another wasted opportunity like almost
the kings of the nikita console just
came out and I'm just seeing these
generic boxes with different stickers
slap though and I'm like what the reason
why you're getting that now when we were
getting the winning boxes is because we
were like close to winning we're in
parity with the systems and as the gap
got wider so did the production on
complete like elaborate consoles now
they're giving you a weird shade of
color like lime green gray some weird
color with Sony and you see the
spider-man system horizon for not to
have when that's your gym do you think I
think it's gone and because of the
losing for you think that is not going
to invest in that right now but nobody
in the marketing department is gonna
fund a situation with is you're not
going to be but we got a box for you
coming the box the whole panel but
realistically let's let's talk about
custom consoles just as a broad subject
age were all at I can't have a
fluorescent shiny vertical standing
console when you walk into the family
room I just can't do it okay I'm sitting
here I jump on the sword of the grenade
for all of us gamers anytime and tell
people don't tell me you're gonna watch
The Bachelor every night and I can't
play video games but I certainly am NOT
gonna have it when you walk into the
family room I'm gonna have all these
consoles that are multi colored all
changed up looking crazy it don't work
like that when you get older so ya know
it's up but here's the thing I am all
about custom castles when it comes to
value ok fright and when it comes to
value I did go pick up the gears ok well
that's right but the second 2x came out
and I saw that some dude was like crazy
who's got gears that's up and down his
back he's like I'll give you 400 for I
was like sold to that
right so right so I'll do the same thing
right now
I just got $250 credit at Gamestop for
my ps4 Pro all right my regular pistol
chrome not fancy on it come up to the
ps4 pro spider-man I'm getting that
spider-man edition oh thank you
it's coming with the game it's coming
with the game right so you take $3 - the
65 who's watching it what it is with tax
in New York okay my dollars I'm buying
that anyway so that's already taking
that thing down to about whatever three
you know 340 250 for my ps4 Pro about
$400 less than on an hour I'm gonna walk
out with this thing and I know that I'm
gonna get at least $300 for this thing
and the training and I'm paid a letter
not a piyo where'd you get the
PlayStation 5 thank you I feel bad for
the horizon for one and it looked real
snazzy but that for surprised a for when
they get you 350 aftermarket that's my
point exactly
so you just the title that it was it
just wasn't something sexy enough to big
it got a package you know it's the end
of the gen we're not really focusing on
this right now we're kind of gearing up
losing position Sony is lapping the
bases so you can get extravagant with
your dances you do dumb things around
the bases as you're winning see like yo
how about we put out 5,000 of those uh
those PlayStation million systems nobody
got but all these uh executives have oh
and I wanted that one like if I was I
definitely would have paid for that one
but I wanted to spider-man but then I
thought oh I don't really play a thing
that much anyway but spider-man looks
very cool I have a real system for the
Xbox one next yeah what but I really
like a crack system with something nice
something snazzy he's like this thing is
grilling me he's like yeah but King
wouldn't a custom console possibly catch
the eye of someone who might be on the
fence that's all I was saying like I'll
just catch that
you know but think about all these
custom consoles and Jonathas singer in
the chat you know like saying I'm with
you on the way you're thinking I really
am but the thing about it is it goes
back to what King originally said when
we talked about this these are all
limited edition
even the Spider Man they're all limited
edition so even those few people that
are gonna change your minds that go and
pick up that other one is it worth it
because from what we heard you know I
had we had what's-his-face there Craig
Duncan on m-and-c
right a shout out to Craig awesome dude
but he said you know the money time and
cost that goes into those in the
planning you know they don't just slap
like when Xbox does they don't you like
to stick around in here right so he got
to get those one or two maybe maybe few
people I shouldn't say one or two but
maybe the 1500 people that weren't going
to that are gonna go do that that's
something I can't answer but I don't
know if that really is dollar for dollar
the amount of money they're putting into
that custom card you can see that's
right so and then I don't think for us
consumers depending on what it is when
you get something like a spider-man or
you get something like a Gears or a halo
okay something like that or maybe even
an uncharted something where you have a
ridiculously large abundance of
followers that I wouldn't pay over the
market value later when it's not
obtainable that's what you have a value
and I don't think if you forced to rise
before listen I'm excited for for to
rise before but I wouldn't give you more
than what's on the shelf for that but I
do see with which they are saying and
that may change people but I don't think
it changes the corporate thought on how
much money they got to spend I see you
now you're making the right point and I
do agree with that that's a valid point
they made you say hey like from that
standpoint it's not solve you got
anything
I got the white one because that was the
only one out at launch otherwise I would
have gotten it so you know the last
crazy console I got was a purple
GameCube that's it cool I'm up the last
one is a gank you've always perform all
right this would be going or this would
be super quick want you to notice how he
ty road
Nintendo so obviously since we only
degree with here with this tab had to be
done
good friends around map is good tel
great the NPD numbers have come out and
obviously Nintendo has won the NPD
something Hardware for July tremendous
tremendous what they're doing right now
yet one squeeze for a big month for them
and of course octo pair traveler the
best-selling nintendo tooks top software
publisher and as far as like accessories
have grown up you know revenue from even
xbox is gonna be even had the UM though
i believe it was the white controller
was like one of top selling accessories
which I thought was very interesting
yeah man so it's just a good time which
is pretty interesting I was the occupied
at one GTA five whole like wow right
like a five is crazy and I just thought
that um also looking at the list as far
as the top ten we had like at least five
switch games name yet octopod
you got Mario Kart you got Selda at five
small seven and you got ten is Mario
Aces so I know what you talked about
this actually offer I didn't listen it's
great segments you guys had on that and
you pay some funny points I'm not to get
into but mediums have some fierce debate
whether this is a switch and I just
would ask one question obviously the
octo path traveller question because I
know we all know that MPD does not count
digital sales so to lord I do you at
least think this is impressive that octo
PAP travelers which gain only the
physical sales will counted one month
look man
it's actually starting to help them out
because I switch every monthly like yo
these five games I get it you know King
goes yeah man I'm gonna get the switch
man I really like the division to know
about that what about desta - about that
what about that what about call of duty
about that damn what do they have the
record is this is not impressed this is
this is nothing that was on top like
let's notice was out look the beginning
of last year selling out games that just
came out it's impressive
Mario karts still selling out games that
just came out it's impressive you know
here's here's the thing attic that you
got to kind of bring up before I lose
ice this is thought you know King said
something earlier in the show where he
goes if you're not first you're just you
know you're in your loser right you have
your first loser always here's something
that's kind of it's hard to even put
this into words but we were saying this
on crossfire the switch is the must own
second console now let me explain this
to you and probably one what are you
talking about that means you've got Xbox
fans and PlayStation fans alike both
sides so you've got the 80 million camp
in the 40 million
arguing over that whole thing they will
let out the other one but the 120
million people buying a switch so my
whole thing is this right you've got
both of them that will split by the
switch it's it's everybody's go to
second so you either here playstation
guys go on the ps4 switch owner here
Xbox got on Xbox and switch but the
switch is always in the conversation and
now with time that's why I think you're
seeing all of their titles all their
software because as people keep going
and keep buying this switch those games
the Marlys the all and listen you guys
always have a guest time you always ask
all your guests you know what's the
what's the games you guys have growing
up people are throwing Zelda at you left
and right the number one so whether you
played breath of the wild whether you
loved it or you hated it when you played
15 minutes or 15 hours my point is that
you bought it right and that's the thing
Nintendo's got that nostalgia that
they've wrapped us all up in they put a
new cigarette and listen I'm a sucker to
I love I love some of those game right
with the Nintendo switch and let me tell
you something the Wii U got a bad rap
but I bought the Wii U day one - okay
day one and the Wii U as bad as because
Nintendo stopped caring about the week
well you know what it was they they they
kind of went to the party and they were
like oh [ __ ] somebody already brought
the dip they were coming back to the
party for there to go back and get the
[ __ ] they needed you know we you had a
tablet they couldn't leave the couch we
just said we were doing that with the
game gear in 1993 so the whole
employment matters they had to go back
into the drawing board and they spit out
a new console really quick and it did a
good job with it they did a hell of a
job I like what the switch is the switch
is not going nowhere so when I see
Nintendo wins NPD we're still on that
Wii U hangover right this is the point
of contention Mirotic had back then is I
don't think enough credit is given to
the fact that switched digital sales are
not coded so that that's why I feel
[Music]
you know when I saw the NPD's come out
I'm not in the corporate boardroom hey
when you're MPD's come out you're
winning you know why this is this I want
to lean on a little secret
cuz I gotta hit it alone
the last place really um my mottos in
the news and this is the very last thing
which I throw a shout-out to solver
bring Mario created the legend here's
some interesting things to say about
what's going on with arm like the
free-to-play model and he thinks that
it's a mistake
he's shunning it you know I'm saying
he's saying it's knit people are nickel
and diming the gamers and instead of
that charging that upfront
one-time fee publishers are increased
egiving games away Assemblyman dis kid
this kind of prices and he's kind of
saying that like that whole behavior is
something like he is completely again he
feels that it starts creativity and game
making and promotes his quote got this
little burg gambling like behavior so a
name which resulted there are lawmakers
in Belgium and then actually to ban lube
boxes I'm gonna get this to low much
like mmm do we take my Amato's not in
touch anymore cuz obviously we see stuff
like fortnight now successful by the
revolution discuss something I don't
think I don't think it's the right
direction I don't think he's out of
touch I'll be honest with you he he's
listen to what you just said right there
I like how you broke it down Cognito
because the will you look at it from an
artist or someone like himself that's
been in the game since the beginning
stop but think about this anybody's
listening right now and anybody on the
panel that has any of their kids playing
Fortnight right like every two hours it
could be two or three every two or three
hours the skins change you can buy them
and these things aren't five dollars
some of these things are twenty dollars
and you know what he's saying is that
instead of developing this game for
tonight which I have a blast plan with
the family I'm not gonna hide that I put
that outside of my sleep I love the game
I do I have a lot of fun with it but
realistically we were playing that same
map forever
instead of getting creative these dudes
are just coming how it like going shark
costumes they give you shark costumes
and we're gonna put a meet here and just
change slightly change them right and
that's what matters mayhem out I was
talking about he's saying instead of
these guys being creative they're more
worried about getting these like these
these costumes switched out to make cash
now don't get me wrong it's a business
but what I'm saying is when you have
this many people and you're making this
kind of money that's a billion-dollar
franchise at this point you should have
a team dedicated to making they should
have the game there's some a team
dedicated to make the game better and
somebody making the skins right now and
this is where he's going with if every
game right and now there's this rumor
that battlefield 5 okay he's gonna have
the ring of fire coming out this ring of
fire which is a battle royale mode it'll
be free-to-play and they're gonna do the
same
things yeah what you're gonna get it
right you're gonna lose people working
on the battlefield five-game to work on
making new skins and guns and different
helmets that you can wear dirt right in
the money's gonna go up but the
creativity is gonna go down and that's
what he's saying so do I think that it's
here's the thing if we just have the big
boys that go and do that and they want
to branch out and have a team dedicated
to making these types of free-to-play
games I say go for it but what Mayim out
I was talking about that such a variant
part of me if I'm saying his name wrong
I apologize but about it right right
think about him what he's saying that's
correct
he's like these teams said he's probably
got working on his first party games in
the Nintendo world they're not gonna
take the talent that is working on these
games and you see okto path traveler
which you know k2 kicks point he makes
it funny point but it is kicking ass
taking names good but I'm saying he
can't take you can't take people off
that development to start making new
skins and free-to-play games these
people are utilizing every single pair
of hands they have to make these great
games right realistically speaking I
myself I don't go as far as some of
these things you see on Twitter where
people go off the deep end they're like
oh my god
Damon's gonna end it's all gonna be like
a we're gonna 55 different versions of
fortnight right no but at the same time
you do have to say as a consumer that it
would be nice if we could just pay the
$60 and get the skins versus every two
hours I got my son tapped me on the
shoulder being like look look I thought
that shark one was cool but now now I
can be like this old retro dude that
looks like this and I'm like I'm like
well where does it end these are $20 a
pop you know your point man it is a
concern it's something to talk about for
absolutely I want to give it back to a
good solvent so what do you think about
the heat because you'd wanna put this to
my attention you feel he's all for what
he's saying is absolutely correct I
think when you're when you're put in a
position where you have to develop a
game and you're constantly having to
update and having to add stuff to it and
in order to keep people engaged there's
no creativity there it's just a matter
of like how do I get this content out
there and what he wants to do I think
the mistake they made let's say was to
Mario run right I think that that
onboarding price of ten dollars up front
I think was too high I think they need
to try to make their games if they want
to make one flat rate of
or a game that's perfect I think that's
what he wants to continue to do because
I think he feels at that point they're
developed they have a vision for the
game they're releasing the game and when
it comes out that's the game and I just
think the price point for people who are
used to purchasing things on mobile
platforms they're used to paying a lot
less for it like right now I'm playing a
game I don't never play mobile games I'm
playing a game that's like a it's called
hold-down and it's like like a brick
breaker type game right four bucks for
that game mmm and I've been blaze in
this game and it's four bucks he's
blazing that game but he's not blazing
and I think he's right in that respect I
think and his thing is he doesn't care
if the other model was making more money
says we're gonna keep doing this until
it's entrenched until they they have to
swallow this running we're gonna make
money that way because natural B gonna
make money that way I think the mistake
they did make Romero and I think it was
too expensive
and and I think moving forward they're
gonna rectify that oh another
interesting thing that he said is that
he sort of said you know what we have to
learn how to play nice with subscription
models I think he sort of gave a big up
to the game pass and what they're trying
to do and he says I don't know what they
plan to do for Nintendo in the future in
the game pass I mean I'm all I'm gonna
say this in a very nice manner to this
man because he is the Godfather of this
industry and it as far as creativity
goes if he's not a touch he is
completely out of touch because he's
working for the same company that would
throw out minis every other month I want
you to start with your fraud in my Amaro
just because somebody's models
successful and your game is over I wish
I would have charged for those with one
hand tied behind his back
listen I'm tired dude looking at
something else as being sick stuff yes
but I don't care put battle royale and
everything you don't have to play you
know what a Mario battle royale may be a
game was still better this one Atta girl
is Gaddafi I want to bring out that you
know it's easy to say something when you
don't have the hot title that he could
do if he had like you know something
that he could have done that was like
this kind of his style what like that
what if there was like a all in intended
like how they got a smash whether they
did it's a battle royale with all smash
character never have your company's a
hundred percent against this fortnight
wouldn't be on the switch it's okay to
be against it when you don't have it but
fight the best friend across the pond
because he got all the hot dogs a
chicken wing guy over but you little
complain about people chicken we was
talking about wasn't so much for the
switch and for like the home console he
was talking about mostly was the mobile
market right right and it'll market and
like the microtransactions our to make
money are straight up to make money and
a lot of times it's you need to pay to
play like it's where you're moving the
game and your pain whereas like for
tonight that's all cosmetic stuff like
he's ready
listen I doubt very much he has a
problem with making you know money off
of skins and whatnot as long as people
have fun with the game yeah the mobile
models different you know I mean I think
that's what he wanted to do I think
Nintendo in general they and there's no
denying that you know regardless how you
feel about their games
a reason there five of them consistently
stay in the top five they know how to
make gains without none of that nonsense
yeah but at the end of the day I feel
like his statement
it wasn't greed it wasn't nothing like
that it wasn't envy it wasn't jealousy
it was just I ain't got that yet so I
don't want that I don't really care for
that kind of playing so how many of
these dad's do you think work on
fortnight that's probably said one point
of time private or public that their day
they don't like nickel and diming people
with the moment they see that paycheck
they like yo what else can we do the
relevant native shot energy
apparently there's a Madden tournament
shooting just now five dead 11 injured
she was killed by police and apparently
he was a contestant that was eliminated
in the toilet so I guess he came back up
and in so recipes to all the people who
lost a lot smoothly
apparently Florida law that's ridiculous
opponent get much out of here all right
new poll with the roommate Xbox monthly
subscription service including the
console Xbox Live in-game pass going to
be announced by Microsoft do you think
this can negatively affect gamers the
choices are a yes targets young gamers
bad credit and financing day be know Pro
consumer friendly option or our favorite
see I don't care what about them
exclusives though that could be that's
in every poll right
[Music]
please like the ILP poll when it comes
on Twitter tomorrow Android mulch
nothing absolutely no stories for days
where people find you and what do you
have cooking up let me say first and
foremost thank you to the Lord for
having me to the round table it is an
honor to be here you know way too long
week we should have done it years ago to
be honest yes and you know what though
it don't it don't matter we got years
left in it so we're gonna do this can't
wait to bring you to the realm of
crossfire you guys some of you guys have
been there but the ones that haven't
need to come on we will make sure that
happens so first and foremost let me say
thank you again everybody here and the
chance
outstanding chat that chat was on fire
today too so thank you to all you guys
for doing that where you can find me is
of course coach 78 on YouTube crossfire
7:00 p.m. Eastern Time Friday night
that's how you start your game and
weekend with us on crossfire and then
you got MNC evenings on Thursdays which
is partially on my channel as well 7:00
p.m. and we will have a we doing a huge
guess that Metacritic it's this third
that you gotta come which is how you
play bowling when we play the theme you
get that spider-man the winner gets the
game
we do a three call we've been doing
three callers a week for the past three
weeks this would be the last week so
we'll have about I think it's gonna have
a total of 12 of contestants and then we
lovers of winner gets the game it's that
central so check it out opportunity 72
no no you know there's too many
spider-man fans in the media to go 72
quality with 96 98 99 and you got to
calm down stop calling him while you're
looking at your at spider-man tattooed I
don't count
you know realistically I think mid-80s
is a legit number I think is what its
gonna yeah I went with 86 the last time
the Mets did anything relevant
just like John Junger I'm going with 91
I play the game addict and King is still
in effect
absolute pleasure man long overdue
yes sir it all about unity it's all
about gaming having fun in all realms
can make that happen
listen to each other we all a game
because we all have our different
opinions but this is the common thread
thank you once again thank you all or
you already know man Lord addict what
you got going on we can't find people
find you ain't doing nothing but getting
this dumb stuff on destiny does any low
videos a little previews we might be
getting why you not playing this well
I'm doing a video probably be out
tomorrow on a all-access but that's all
dedicated to destiny sit here be told I
can't enter the room to play the Ray
because I ain't big enough to ride this
roller coaster Louis wicked people not
find you playing offline and not like
this Miami plan does definitely find me
playing the messenger on Thursday pick
up whatever platform you're playing off
pick up today yes beautiful gay
spiritual ninja gayden successor but
with those devs out in packs he's
fantastic fantastically playing the
meeting like a day before you had it
scheduled you know I was a little
thirsty for that word that was good
that's what's up so lord King wicked
fapping fine
you can find me on xbox you can find me
on Twitter actually getting bombarded by
these fearful police listen listen crap
all the time I really love his stuff I
listened to the podcast when I get a
chance and the fact that you're here and
the numbers is still at 70 watching and
the like some people negative and for
those people I know for you even to sit
here and I'll put a negative yeah you
still like the show burning that the
world didn't blow up and I never will
because at the end of the day he's gonna
go pick up a controller just like I am
thing we're gonna gain thanks what
listen oh you guys are getting this
thing weird it and mixed up that
Instagram is not my Instagram all right
now so don't think that you putting
messages to me because I'm not looking
at them I don't think you know you
commented on pitches and haha I don't
care
that is an IO P public page that four
people have access to that four people
put pitches in that four people could
put add people to I don't add people I
don't know who after you are I don't
want to be on one thing to get it
misconstrued that you guys think it's
Kings but it isn't all right the same
thing if you understood about the
Facebook now if you want to individually
interact with any one of us we all have
Twitter if you go to the ILP Twitter
page we are all there and you can click
on us and talk to us but if you think
you're doing it in Instagram talking to
me I don't hear you alright so just
leave me alone
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
not so much a lot of stuff some more
special things hopefully in the work for
September I don't want to blow the lid
off that again thank you so much hit the
like the subscribe to UM the inner
circle Network all the media outlets
tick was last night multi versus up
again double xp the whole gang also more
Chi box who will have the time stamps up
in the description for the audio later
tonight I want to shout out the string
team Lord some now though you don't say
super G ocean scale a l-boogie we got
some more things cooking up a new sign
me Lord
Nick Tendo direct will be who did the
paperwork done getting signing going you
don't say but we gonna have some stuff
cooking up with him
and of course my destiny lovers on the
ILP channel flashpoint 28 witty bond
test was up fantastic you getting ready
for us a kid if you're getting hype if
you want to come back please this is the
time to check it out and of course thank
you to all the patients we really
appreciate we're trying to continue to
bring good content I know we went long
lower shadow Jonathan be said this was
the longest intro of ILP ever you are
hilarious but we gotta get out of here
everyone enjoy this Sunday anybody got
anything else good that's a good all
right let's get outta here man thank you
everybody
alright
[Music]
you
[Music]